foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we're here with TK
Coleman what it is Alabama's here hi
everybody got the rest of the team in
the studio today and coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about
suffering from stuffitis what a disease
that is she's inflamed by too much stuff
we also have an outstanding lightning
round listener tip and added value
segment for you you can check out the
full two and a half hour maximal edition
of episode 363 where we answer four
times the questions and we dive deep
into several simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com the minimalists your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free because say it with
me y'all
advertisements suck Alabama where are we
starting today let's start with a
question from Michaela in Wisconsin
hi this is Michaela from Wisconsin I
currently live with my parents until I
am financially able to move out on my
own while I've been living with them
I've been saving up things for a future
house that I think I may want or need
uh due to this I now have about 50
clutter coffins down in their basement
and it's definitely too much but every
time I go through the stuff I like it
and I want to keep it how do you decide
what to get rid of if you like
everything that you have
uh our society is definitely suffering
from this illness called stuffitis and I
heard this term first from Dave Ramsey
when he was in our last documentary less
is now on Netflix and he was talking
about how it creeps up it becomes a
chronic illness in a way when you think
about stuff we all know what stuff is it
could be material possessions but all
the stuff in our heads we were talking
about that earlier on the private
podcast how our thoughts get turned way
up there's a lot of stuff in our head
which is often a symptom of the stuff in
our lives we could talk about the stuff
in our relationship I'm just going
through some stuff in my career right uh
you know this thing has been going on at
church or with my community center
whatever it is there's a lot of stuff
going on right now see we know what
stuff is we're talking here about
material stuff but it can be other stuff
as well and then itis which just means
to be inflamed right so when you hear
about like colitis it means your colon
is inflamed right and so we were
inflamed by stuff and so we're talking
to someone like Michaela here she said
there's a lot of stuff here that I need
or or maybe that I want and Ryan and I a
few years ago we came up with the this
rule we call it the No Junk rule to
differentiate between three things it's
the stuff that you need the stuff that
you want and the stuff that you kind of
like and there's a difference here I
would actually look at those
categorically as three substantially
different things so you can download the
minimalist rulebook you can read the No
Junk rule in there it's free you can
find our website the minimalists.com
right there at the top you can just
download or you can go to our free
resources page but what I'll tell you is
with respect to the No Junk rule
everything you own fits in one of three
piles it's either
essential
it's non-essential but adds value or
it's junk another way to look at that is
you need it
you want it because it adds value to
your life or yeah I kind of like that or
I think I'm supposed to like that but
maybe it's actually getting in the way
and that's the junk and if you can
differentiate between all those clutter
coffins that she calls them in her
basement we did a whole episode called
clutter coffins we'll put a link to that
episode in the show notes because that's
what happens we bury our stuff very
neatly in our basements and attics we
put it in these clutter coffins and all
of a sudden we have to deal with it or
Worse we just put it off till tomorrow
because yeah I think I like some of
these things I know I don't actually
need them if you needed them they
wouldn't be buried in your basement
right if they added value to your life
they wouldn't be buried in your basement
what we're really talking about is some
hypothetical future value you may get
from those things and that is true but
you'll never get the value as long as
they're tucked away hidden from use
that's right like if you only like it
when you look at it you probably should
give it away so you you don't have to
look at it but but no seriously if you
only like something when you look at it
that's probably the strongest argument
you can find that you don't love it
imagine if we treated people like that I
mean hey Ryan I never think about you I
never wonder how you're doing I never
feel curious about you I'm never
motivated to initiate contact with you
oh but whenever you happen to show up
and you're right there yeah I like you
that's not love man that's not the
foundation of a great friendship right
we wouldn't really tolerate that in our
personal relationship so why tolerate it
with things I mean that's really the
definition of shopping looking at a
bunch of stuff that you feel compelled
to buy when you're looking at it but
then as soon as you turn your head and
look the other way it's like oh I don't
really need that yeah yeah it's
difficult man like we hang on to these
things because we keep them for some
non-existent hypothetical future or
maybe it is an existence hypothetical
future in Michaela's case but you know
the stories that we tell ourselves I
mean these are important man like every
single story that whether it's our
Narrative of our life The Narrative of
how we got here where we're going uh
these stories are so important so the
story that we tell ourselves when we
hold on to things a lot of the times is
oh yeah one day yeah I'm gonna use that
one day I I'm gonna I'm gonna put that
in a I'm gonna put that in a bin because
one day that's gonna look really really
good in this home that I'm gonna get in
the future and there's nothing wrong
with that story the problem is is when
that story isn't serving us and that's
what I would ask anyone in a situation
where they're holding on to things for
some non-existent hypothetical future is
how is that story serving you if it's
making you leap for joy and it's
motivating you to go out and and and and
get it and buy that house whatever it
may be that all that stuff's going to go
into one day then great hold on to your
stuff but if that story if it's holding
you back if it's making you anxious well
then you might want to you might want to
rewrite that story a little bit oh man
one day itis
maybe that's what you just tapped into
as the real Foundation of stuff itis all
of the stuff we hang on to that we don't
need whether it's a toxic relationship a
job that we should have quit a long time
ago it's based on this Narrative of one
day itis one day I'm gonna get my life
together one day I'm gonna truly love
myself one day I'm gonna do something
that really brings me joy one day I'm
gonna live life like I really want to
live it but until that day comes I'll
hang on to this just in case
relationship this just in case job this
just in case item and you never Bill a
passionate adventurous life off of just
in case you know the first day of every
year I tweet the same tweet
and it's simply this
one day
or day one you decide
and I think that's applicable to any day
obviously we don't need to wait till New
Year's to have the resolution in our
life with respect to our stuff and I
think Michaela if you're listening to
this right now
it's
day one you don't have to wait for one
day today is day one the first day of
letting go because yes you may be
suffering from stuffitis as I think we
all are if the average American
household has 300 000 items in it we're
all inflamed with unnecessary material
items things that get in the way and so
as Ryan said a moment ago if the things
are getting in the way that is a
Surefire sign that you want to let go
the reason you're calling in is because
you know you want to let go of some of
it you know some of it's in the way and
so it's figuring out what is essential
none of those things are essential we
know that because they're tucked away in
these Carter coffins so what are the
things that are non-essential but add
value to your life and you can identify
those by identifying the third category
what is the junk what are the things
that are getting in the way what is the
Clutter because the definition of
clutter for us as the minimalists is
anything that gets in the way of living
a meaningful life and so something that
doesn't get in the way today something
that serves you today may get in the way
tomorrow or a year from now and so we're
constantly questioning we're asking does
this add value to my life and if it
doesn't man
that's a sign to let it go one last
thing a rule that we put up on
YouTube recently so we've got the
minimalist rule book 16 rules for living
with less and we're constantly making up
new rules as we go as we learn new
things at one of our Sunday Symposium
events here in Los Angeles I talked
about so someone came up and they're
asking a question about all these things
they wanted to move with but they don't
even know some of the stuff they own
and I think that's where Michaela is
right now she goes down into those
clutter coffins before opening them
she looks at him and says I don't really
know what's in here or when she opens up
she may even say hey I didn't know I
owned this thing but now that I know
what I feel compelled to hold on to it
but here's the rule it's called the
don't know Roar didn't know rule if I
didn't know
that I owned it five minutes ago
and I know that I own it now if I didn't
know that I owned it I can let it go
and don't fight to keep anything that
you're not fighting to use
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text message you
can text your questions your comments
your concerns your emojis to
937-202-4654 yes indeed we answer those
questions regularly especially here on
the podcast also if you're on our text
list we'll send you a Monday morning
minimal Maxim every Monday a little
something pithy something insightful
something simple to start off your week
with a dose of Simplicity malibam looks
like we got a question here from Sydney
how do you deal with the anxiety of
wanting something gone immediately but
taking the time to actually go through
the box or scan all the papers is too
overwhelming it is overwhelming here's
what I'll say during the lightning round
each of us we do our best to answer
questionable the short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maximums in the
show notes which you can find over at
the minimalists.com podcast
that way you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like put 60 seconds on the clock for me
Professor Sean so Sydney it's hard to
find a needle in a haystack
it's even harder to find it in a needle
stack
um
let me expand on that real quick because
I have a little bit of time on the clock
I often would go into my basement when I
own these hordes of stuff
and I knew I had a thing or thought I
had the thing because I had all of these
things that I thought were meaningful to
me everything that I had was significant
to me but of course if everything's
significant how could any of it possibly
be significant it's overwhelming so I'm
not going to deal with it although you
still have to deal with it you deal with
it because it becomes mental clutter it
becomes spiritual clutter it's not just
physical clutter and it becomes time
clutter right because now I'm going down
there I'm dealing with it every time I'm
looking for a thing that I want it's
covered up by a hundred things that I
don't want so you have to deal with it
whether it's now or later you are
dealing with it that's so good yeah
um my pity my it's pithy right I always
man I'm so sorry
all right
if it's not worth sorting through it's
not worth keeping when you look at that
box of stuff does it make you feel like
Christmas where it's like ah you're
filled with anticipation and you just
want to open it up to see what's inside
so that you can figure out a way to use
it if it feels like Christmas keep it
keep it around that brings a lot of joy
to your life on the other hand if it
makes you feel like ah exasperated and
sad why do that to yourself there's
nothing wrong with doing things that are
painful and difficult and uncomfortable
but you should only do such things when
they are pragmatically necessary or if
there is some higher aim or purpose for
why you do them yeah put up with
difficult family members sometimes yeah
put up with the pain of working out
there's a higher aim and purpose for
doing those things but if that box and
stuff is creating pain in your life and
there's no higher aim or purpose for it
get rid of everything that doesn't feel
like Christmas Ryan what I love about
what TK is saying here is that if it
feels like Christmas wonderful but if it
feels like your credit card after
Christmas yeah that stress that anxiety
that why did I do this why did I buy
this why did I keep it then yeah I'm
gonna have to let it go did that count
towards my time right there
if it doesn't feel like Christmas you
better have a reason for putting up with
it that feels like Christmas Hmm this is
becoming pitheater less than pythorless
throw a clock on give me 60 seconds all
right uh here's my pity answer internal
clutter is a side effect of external
clutter so at its Terminus let's look at
a hoarder right they have so much stuff
they're it's literally crushing them in
some cases and what is happening is
there is an internal struggle going on
that they have to deal with first and
that is often what we have to do we have
to deal with that internal struggle
struggle first before we we handle these
external things now sometimes our stuff
maybe maybe we're not struggling maybe
it's just inconvenient but you know I
could look at working out as
inconvenient last night I had to do my
uh physical therapy exercises I had to
do them at nine o'clock at night I
didn't want to do them it was hard it
was difficult I pushed through and not
only did I push that discomfort but I
got something out of it where I'm like
oh I have to plan my days different so
when we push through that discomfort
that is really where we learn a lot but
if you can't push discomfort maybe you
want to deal with that external clutter
first yeah I think one confers the other
right you've got all of this clutter the
external clutter leads to the internal
clutter and it the internal clutter then
breathes what more external clutter we
got a lot more to talk about on the
private podcast we've got some other
segments for you a little home tour but
first Alabama what do you got for us
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners hi minimalists this is
Susan from the Netherlands I'm a huge
Board Game Fan so naturally I have a lot
of board games when I started
decluttering them I would not ask myself
whether I enjoy the game or whether I
would like to play it instead I'd ask
myself whether I own a similar game that
I would rather play
this helped me to get rid of games that
I really like but that I would never
play
for me this heuristic also works for
shoes or clothes I ask myself every time
that I could wear this would I rather
wear something else if so I can safely
get rid of it all right y'all before we
get to our added value segment this week
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist coming up uh next
weekend it's open for two days only I
teach a writing class two or three times
a year it's called how to write better
and registration enrollment opens for 48
hours or the first 100 students whenever
comes first I've been teaching this for
almost a decade now TK man up I've
learned so much from teaching right in
fact it improved my own writing I've had
high school students I've had English as
a second language students I've had
medical doctors take this class and what
we've learned is the rising tide lifts
all boats I give you the resources you
need to improve your riding if you want
to write that first book if you want to
start a blog if you're looking at
writing better business emails so you
can better communicate with your
co-workers or clients how to
writebetter.org how to write better is
the name of the class it's four weeks
you can take it at your own pace though
you can take it up to 16 weeks if you
want it's designed to be uh four weeks
long and it's a bunch of different
videos it's 60 different written pages
of materials I think 22 different videos
that are dripped out to you over the
course of four weeks and what my
guarantee to you is that if you take
this course you will indeed learn how to
write better how to radically improve
your writing just give me four weeks of
your time and I will show you how to
write better or you can take my class
how to write
gooder.org you got time for a question
about your course yeah go for it they
say the best way to learn something is
by teaching it I'm curious what's one
thing you have learned as a writer that
has improved you as a result of teaching
you know I have a bunch of writing tips
that I wrote after starting the class so
there's this free book you can download
over at how to writebetter.org it's
called 15 ways to write better yeah and
a few of them this really stand out to
me one is to with punctuation being pace
and so what I've learned is the way that
we write it has to do you know we often
write how we speak but if we change the
punctuation just a little bit and this
is one of the things I teach in the
class how to improve your punctuation
you can actually improve the reader
experience because ultimately writing
well has to do with communicating with
other people and expressing whatever you
want to express and the most succinct
and also the most compelling way that
gets the reader that gives them that
sense of narrative urgency that moves
them forward to the next sentence to the
next page to the next book whatever it
might be and I've learned a whole lot
about my own writing you're right
especially the first three years of
teaching the course I would say my
writing probably improved a thousand
percent just because I was learning
these little things I was breaking down
my own recipe and as soon as you break
down the recipe you learn these little
nuances here's one more thing that
really
as I started teaching this to the
students I learned that
what makes your writing compelling is
that you are simultaneously more
compelling and less compelling than you
think and I'll leave that as a
cliffhanger but if you want to check out
the course it opens this week in October
28th and 29th how to write better.org
you can also head over there and
download the free ebook 15 ways to write
better for added value segment this week
we have a friend Ryan Michael gunger oh
yeah he and his wife have a band called
Gungor we love them they're awesome her
voice is unbelievable like she's got I
love her voice we like his voice too but
yeah but you know
she's got she's got that um ethereal
thing going on I can't even explain it
other than that well if you're listening
to the audio version of the podcast and
the song that is playing in the
background that is a song from gungor's
new album the album is called a love
song to life and the song is called a
million eyes
and as an eye like I me myself I
but the song the whole album is like
worship music for people who aren't used
to worship music it's not religious in
the traditional sense although they come
out of that tradition and I found I put
the album on as almost this meditative
experience and the whole album is
beautiful it just came out you can check
it out by Gungor we'll put a link to it
in the show notes if you're watching the
YouTube public version of the podcast
then there'll be a link somewhere above
my left shoulder and you can check out
the audio version on YouTube of a
million eyes by Gungor by the way TK we
got a bunch more surprise questions on
the private podcast this week like one
of the best ways to minimize Tech
clutter and the desire to upgrade how do
I let go of my old journals sketch pads
notebooks pins and pencils why are
walk-in closets a complete waste of
space plus a million more questions for
the minimalists and if they want to hear
all that in Alabama tell them what the
check out the minimalist private podcast
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description to
subscribe and get your personal links so
that our weekly maximal episodes play in
your favorite podcast app you'll also
gain immediate access to all of our
archives recordings of Live Events
weekly home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you in fact here's a
thoughtful testimonial from one of our
lovely patreon supporters Ava says thank
you so much for your private podcasts
I've been listening to the public
version for years as a single mother who
is on a minimalism Journey I've been
decluttering my monthly subscriptions
but I've been getting so much motivation
from you over the years and even more
recently that I finally decided I need
more of less more of less that's what we
provide with the the private podcast
from Alabama if folks want to comment on
this episode what do they do they can
comment at youtube.com the minimalist
and if they have a question in our
listener tip for our podcast give us a
call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast the minimalist.com follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalists
and to get our podcast show notes in
your inbox sign up for our email list at
theminimalist.com thank you Alabama that
is our show for today on behalf of Ryan
Nicodemus TK Coleman podcast Sean
malabama Jordan no more Professor Sean
social just Danny unknown
post-production Peter Emma The Immigrant
and the rest of our team I'm Joshua
Fields Wilburn if you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign